[Musica]
A proposito di tempo sprecato che non si
spreca mai il tempo perché il tempo
bisogna sfruttarlo e bisogna goderselo
sempre e oltretutto Bisogna vivere nel
presente ve avranno detto un milione di
volte poi il tempo in realtà cambia
anche molto da come lo percepiamo noi
Einstein a un certo punto per spiegare
la relatività in parole semplici Questa
è una delle poche frasi vere di Einstein
al quale vengono attribuite un sacco di
minchiate in
realtà lui disse che la relatività si
spiega così dipende tutto la percezione
del tempo dalla dal lato della porta in
cui ti trovi un mio amico Invece la
spiega secondo me un po' meglio di
Einstein e cioè la
relatività la proviamo veramente quando
da bambini dobbiamo asare per entrare in
acqua dopo aver mangiato la pizzetta al
mare e questa è la cosa più simile a
sperire l'infinito probabilmente non ha
torto E poi c'è anche la questione del
fatto che tutti noi siamo abituati a
giocare a Tetris esistenziale nelle
agende per incastrare tutti gli impegni
e cercare di sfruttare il tempo ma come
mai Da dove viene questa foga
probabilmente
eh sappiamo che il tempo non è infinito
cioè il nostro tempo non è infinito è
tanto ma non è tutto il
tempo e io mi rendo conto che insomma è
tutto causato da una brutto concetto che
a me sta molto antipatico ed è un tabù È
una di quelle cose che non si dice
soprattutto quando sei su un palco e
devi intrattenere però mi tocca farlo
cioè la morte
Eh la morte rende il nostro tempo finito
e ognuno ci fa pace in qualche modo io
purtroppo sono ateo per cui Mi mancano
un po' tutti gli strumenti e le armi che
ha chi crede Ok però ho provato a trarre
una conclusione affrontarle A modo mio
cioè un po' scientifico se vogliamo
l'alternativa a essere mortali è
ovviamente essere
immortali Allora facciamo una prova un
esercizio facciamo finta di essere noi
solo noi non tutti gli altri Proviamo a
far finta di essere immortali Da questo
momento figo e un po' come per chi l'ha
visto Cioè nel senso Le regole sono
queste siamo immortali quindi non
invecchiamo non si vede Non cambiamo nel
tempo e non ci ammaliamo non perdiamo
facoltà fisiche figata probabilmente
quello che succederebbe Almeno a me
succederebbe così poi non so voi è che
nella prima settimana Proveremo tutte ma
anche di più di una settimana forse
Proveremo tutte quelle cose che abbiamo
sempre avuto paura di fare ok parapendio
buttarsi col
paracadute fare delle risse per Chi è
incline vedere tutto Sanremo dopo
festival compreso quelle cose
pericolosissime che non faresti mai e
passata questa ubriacatura diciamo
probabilmente ci sarebbe anche poi
l'aspetto in cui cerchiamo di mettere a
disposizione del resto dell'umanità
perché siamo super supereroi Ok per cui
potremmo fare che ne so i soccorritori
sui teatri di guerra gli artificieri
fare quelli che vanno a recuperare
persone in posti super impervi perché
tanto non moriamo e ci son Anche
l'aspetto economico Nel senso che è
probabile che riusciremmo a mettere via
dei soldi una volta al mese come
cerchiamo di fare tutti quanti però
vivendo centinaia di anni a un certo
punto metteremo via un bel mucchio non
solo che se anche il più scarso
Probabilmente al sessantesimo tentativo
imbrocca una startup che funziona occhio
croce per cui Pam E queste sono le cose
belle poi iniziano quelle brutte Prima
di tutto Ovviamente gli affetti se sei
immortale e quindi solo voi A meno che
non siate qua con tutti i vostri affetti
ma non credo inizier reste a vedere
scomparire le persone a cui volete bene
non solamente i partner la partner anche
i figli che è la cosa più brutta e poi i
figli dei figli sarebbe un po'
insostenibile da un punto di vista
emotivo probabilmente diventeremo molto
Cinici molto freddi e rifug diremmo
dagli affetti come dalle malattie brutte
sarebbe l'unica malattia che potremmo
prendere peraltro perché siamo immortali
Tolti gli effetti c'è l'altro problema
che sembra più terreno se vuoi però non
è un dettaglio cioè quello della noia a
un certo punto t' annoia praticamente
tutto Hai un sacco di tempo per cui
probabilmente a un certo punto studi
qualunque cosa impari letteralmente
tutto ma inizi a diventare refrattario
perché si perde la novità Cioè nel senso
un tramonto è bello 20 volte bello 4.000
volte dopo un po' scassa Ok è un po'
come tutte le cose Probabilmente
rimarremmo legati Ma Ma questa è una mia
supposizione ai piaceri più terreni tipo
la pizza quelle cose lì che non stancano
tanto però non
bastano percezione del tempo cambia
anche quella Vi ricordate quando eravamo
bambini Eh quando andavamo al mare o
comunque facevamo le vacanze Insomma il
periodo di iato a scuola in cui si stava
a casa 3 mesi che ci sembrava un'epoca
lunghissima tornavamo in classe poi alla
fine ed eravamo tutti diversi noi ci
sentivamo diversi i nostri compagni
erano tutti diversi Ad invece un attimo
ok Perché non facciamo tre mesi di ferie
il più delle volte però non è solamente
quello in realtà è che quando hai 67
anni 3 mesi d'estate sono più o meno Se
non ricordo male una roba tipo un voto
della nostra esistenza che sembra poco
ma una bella fetta se ne hai 50 anche se
fai 3 mesi d'estate perché sei un baby
pensionato
eh È un attimo è un attimo la stessa
cosa succede Ovviamente se la espandi
perché sei diventato immortale qualunque
cosa duri meno di decenni è praticamente
un battito di ciglia per cui
ricapitolando sei solo o sola cinico
freddo annoia
Tiso ogni cosa ti sembra passare sotto
lo sguardo senza che neanche la tu
riesca a notarla tantomeno apprezzarla
Figurati Con ogni probabilità sei un po'
abbacchiato Seo proprio molto molto
depresso o depressa oppure hai sbroccato
completamente che ci sta è in questa
situazione che ti ri conto che il peggio
deve ancora venire tu sei mortale il
pianeta no facciamo finta
che l'umanità a un certo punto si sia
ripigli ok e che non si sia estinta come
stiamo facendo adesso a un certo punto
ci riprendiamo per cui Cerchiamo di non
devastare il mondo noi ma comunque a un
certo punto il sole esplode lo sapete Sì
ok Di solito non ci riguarda perché
nessuno di noi è veramente immortale
però se sei immortale diventa un
problema
arriva quel giorno il sole esplode
quindi il pianeta viene
polverizzato tutti gli altri vengono
polverizzati tu vedi uno spettacolo
meraviglioso ma non lo puoi raccontare a
nessuno e ti ritrovi letteralmente a
fluttuare nello spazio per sempre senza
cellulare Tra
l'altro e probabilmente pensi che tutto
sommato essere immortali è una
merda quindi per ritornare al discorso
iniziale
sembra strano ma la vita è bella proprio
perché il tempo scorre nel senso è come
ascoltare un vinile Ok stai ascoltando
un vinile e non vuoi che la canzone
finisca tu puoi fermare il disco ma non
si sente niente Cioè la vita si sente se
il tempo scorre senò un silenzio
assordante questo non è che renda
proprio la morte bella Mi rendo conto ma
se non altro Il trascorrere del tempo un
po' meno
pesante che bisogna goderselo ma senza
sensi di colpa senza quella roba del se
non vivo il presente o vivo ogni attimo
Allora faccio schifo come essere umano e
non posso giocare alla Play perché devo
andare a abbracciare il nonno e che poi
un giorno non ci sarà più Io non ho
nella Play nel nonno per cui lo dico un
po' con leggerezza però è
così Divertitevi e adesso il tempo
veramente finito però finita la
Ted
[Applauso]
Grazie
n